oh okay I'm first I'm Nanea Reeves and
I'm CEO trip and thank you I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about my story
when I was a little girl my mother was a
heroin addict and I had two younger
sisters and I felt like the weight of
the world was on my shoulders and I was
so angry to have so much responsibility
at such a young age and that anger
fueled a lot of self-destructive
behavior and me and my sisters and by
the time I was in my early teens I had a
complete mental breakdown that put me in
the hospital and through that experience
I met a woman who was a very kind and
compassionate therapist who taught me
how to meditate and it was in that safe
space that she created that I was able
to quiet the noise in my head and see a
new vision of myself and of my life
going forward that had hope and optimism
for the first time but my sister
couldn't do that she could only see
herself through the lens of being
damaged and by many many years of that
noise in her head just getting louder
and louder she ended up dying from a
drug overdose in 2012 and she lived out
the life I was supposed to have the same
life that my mother lived but I started
to make different choices in my life and
it got better and I met a man who was
handsome and funny and smart and we were
crazy about each other and at the time I
was an artist and you know very bohemian
living a life of self-expression and he
took care of me and we got married and
we bought a house and then one day he
got sick and he couldn't work anymore so
I had to go get a real job and I went to
go work at a web development company in
an office which is pretty much the worst
thing you can ever tell
artists to go do and I thought I was
gonna die and you know it and I had I
had taught myself how to code websites
back when it was actually kind of hard
to do it and I've always been technical
I was this weird little girl that took
apart the TV and put it back together to
see how it worked and when I would play
games at the arcade all the boys would
go whoa and and I love playing video
games because they helped me escape my
life and I could be a hero and a builder
and a maker when it seemed like
everything was falling apart around me
and so I took that skill that I had and
this love of technology to work with me
in that office and I loved it and who
knew that building software with the
team of people could be so much fun even
when it was challenging but just so
incredibly amazing when you built
something as a team together that
actually worked
and so that illness that my husband had
which I thought was taking away my
ability to pursue my dreams actually
gave me a career in tech I didn't even
know I wanted let alone would love as
much as I do and that that small company
I want to go work at it got bought by a
bigger company and I started to meet
everybody in LA tech and people in
Silicon Valley and they actually they
really liked me because I had a lot of
moxie and I had a detector that
can only be had by someone who's been
through a lot of and I had this
weird ability to get very hard things
done and it came from being that little
girl who had to step up and take care of
her two little sisters when her mother
couldn't and that same little girl who
had to figure out how to do things way
beyond her years because of neglect
so that childhood experience that had
scarred me it actually laid the
foundation for what would be some of my
strongest attributes and my career
started to advance but being a woman
in tech as mentioned is not always easy
and especially when I went to go work in
the video game industry I often felt
like I wasn't being heard and that I was
dismissed or shut out of the boys club
and I was working on a mobile game
company that was just starting to really
take off back when people said no one
will ever want to play a game on their
cell phone and some of you are doing
that right now
and I packed up my office one day in
such a state of rage and I took the
boxes down to the car with tears
streaming down my face and I made a
phone call to a friend and I said I
can't do this they they don't treat me
right
and he said Nene you can't leave that
company's on the verge of going public
in about a year do you know how many
people would kill to be in the position
you're in right now you have to stay and
I knew he was right and I said well I
guess anybody can do pushups in their
cell for a year I can stay for a year
and he said let me make another
suggestion that you if you are going to
stay you show up with a good attitude
even if you have to fake it and so I did
that I put my game face on and I went to
work and I showed up with a good
attitude and what a surprise when I
changed they changed they liked me
better I got promoted and when my
initiatives actually started to make a
real difference on the company's success
I got a seat at the table and not just
the seat they give the girls I got a
real seat with real power and I almost
walked away from all of that and what I
could see was one is really important
who you take advice from and two I
wasn't playing the game the game was
playing me and when I flipped that and
showed up like a team player and said
how can I help us all win I started to
get the same cash and prizes that the
boys got provided that I negotiated as
hard as they did which was a very
painful lesson to learn the hard way but
I will say that that company did go
public and had I raged quit that day
there would be someone else standing
here tonight right now but having
success in business doesn't make you
bulletproof from life and three years
ago my husband got diagnosed with
terminal liver cancer and yeah he had a
very healthy attitude about dying he was
a very deep meditator and he insisted
that we all be joyful around him during
the last few months of his life we were
told that we had eight months together
and we only had eight weeks and we all
came together around him with joy and
and love and it was hard but as a result
when he did finally die in his
meditation room which is where he wanted
to leave he was surrounded by all of us
who loved him and it was beautiful and
had I made that moment about me caving
into my sadness at the thought of losing
him he would have seen in his last
breath the person he loved the most in
complete despair and I would have missed
the most profound and meaningful moment
of our relationship was which was to be
there with him with love and gratitude
for the journey we had had and I
definitely had a lot of time to cave in
to my sadness during the past three
years it was a moment though in my
meditation out as I started to emerge
from it that I realized I needed to give
my self compassion and to make the
choice to look at my future without him
with hope and optimism and so I started
to make some decisions about how I
wanted to rebuild my life I got a dog I
never had a dog and I decided that I
only wanted to work with people I really
loved were
and so I love working with my co-founder
of trip
Zach Norman this is our fourth company
working together and I wanted to take
the three things I love the most video
games meditation and compassion these
things that have saved my life and put
them together in a company to do
something wonderful and unique and I
also decided that it was time for me to
stop being number two and to step up and
be a CEO and thank you so that little
girl who's been spending her whole life
taking care of everyone else has finally
started to take care of herself
and I would just like to end with one
thing because it was such a strange
realization yesterday that woman who
helped me in that therapist she was also
a screenwriter and her name was Victoria
Riskin and she went on to become the
very first female president of the
Writers Guild and now she is in the
later stages of her life as a living as
a human rights activist so I'd like to
thank her for her kindness and
compassion to me
and for being a fine example of what it
means to be a badass woman and a fine
human being so thank you very much
you